من الدوحه يا منورنا كل صباح مراسل صباح
العربيه نايف سجين نايف يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك امس رحله نهايه رحله المنتخبات
الاسيويه على يد البرازيل وكرواتيا حدثنا
كيف كانت اجواء المباريات والخروج الاسيوي
من المونديال
نتكلم عن المنتخب الكرواتي والمنتخب
الياباني كلنا يعني شاهدنا احداث المباراه
ولكن لاننا نتحدث عن ما بعد المباراه في
الكواليس يعني كان هناك عدم رضا على
المستوى الذي قدمه المنتخب الكرواتي
والاداء الذي قدمه وكان يعني سبب كبير
للجماهير الكويتيه وايضا حتى وسائل
الاعلام هنا بسبب ان المنتخب همم يذهب
بعيدا في مونديال بسبب المستوى الذي يقدمه
في همم الفتره الماضيه اما في اليابان
هناك يعني همم رغم انه يعني كان ادائهم
رائع جدا وقدموا مستوى مميز وفوظه سيطرتهم
لكن الياباني لم ينسيهم هذا الامر عن همم
خطتهم نعلم ان اليابان وضعت خطه طويله
الماده تقريبا اكثر من 40 عام حتى عام 20
خمسه وخمسين هذه الخطه لديها مؤشرات
واهداف اذا لم تتحقق معناها ان هناك خلل
ضمن هذه الخطه ان يصل منتخب اليابان في 20
22 الى الدور الثمانيه ونعلم ان المنتخب
خرج من دور 16 لذلك كان هناك بالامس
مطالبات كبيره بالتحقيق في اسباب عدم
تحقيق اهداف الخطه واذا كان هناك امور
اثبت على هذا الامر همم وليتم حتى التسليم
الخطه حسب ما وضعت وتحقق اهدافها في همم
المرحله المقبله في نقطه لافته همم
بالامس يعني رغم الشعبيه الكبيره للمنتخب
البرازيلي وايضا حتى المنتخب الكرواتي بعد
وصافته
للمونديال همم روسيا الماضي لانه يعني
يعني انا لمست همم شخصيه لانه في تعاطف مع
المنتخب
الاسيويه يعني كان في تعاطف كبير مع
المنتخب الياباني كان في تعاطف كبير مع
المنتخب همم الكوري كان في جماهير عربيه
تدعم قبيل ال- ال- الاسيا الاسيويين هناك
يعني حاله يعني انا شوف انها ايجابيه نوعا
ما دائما المنتخبات الاقل همم
يعني متعاطف مع اليابان وكوريا وعم تهاجم
كرواتيا واداءها رغم انها فايزه
همم انا همم كنت بكمل لك الموضوع وانا من
ضمنهم ترى من ضمن المجموعه اللي دائما
تتعاطف مع المنتخبات الاقل يعني وانا
لاحظتها يمكن لاني في المونديال سهام
فاعيش الاجواء وتؤثر فيها
دائما الدعم الكل المنتخبات الاقل يبغون
تكون توصل لمراحل متقدمه ودائما الاثاره
ومتى تكون يعني امس فوز البواسير كل شافه
طبيعي لكن لو تخيل لو فازت همم كوريا هنا
بيكون الحدث همم
حتى بالنسبه لنا احنا ك- اعلاميه داخل
مكتمل ومجتمع همم سهام كريستيانو رونالدو
دائما يعني المصاعب واعتقد انه يعيش فتره
صعبه جدا يعني تخيلي النجم ال- ال- ال-
النجم البرتغال الاول همم
70% من المشاركين في الاست اه طالب
وبيبعاد كريستيانو عن تشكيل الاساسيه هذا
يعني امر
اخر مباراه للملعب 974 الاول في العالم
القابل للتفكير
صح
همم على فكره كل الملعبين حتى استاد
الجنوب همم
كانت امس اخر مباراه همم سيتم تخفيض مقاعد
ستاد الجنوب من 40,000 الى الى 20,000 حتى
يعني يستوعب الاحداث التي ستقام في قطر في
الفتره المقبله وكما يعني ذكرنا ملعب
907 او 74 اصلا سهام همم انت لو تشوفين
مكانه وهو مقام بالقرب من الميناء يعني
حتى مكان مؤقت همم قريب من الميناء بعيد
شويه عن همم عن وسط الدوحه همم فهو من
الاساس التخطيط له حتى اختيار مكانه حتى
محطه المترو همم سهام ما توصل ب- قريب من
من اسماء لانه صنع من 974 حاويه في
الميناء شكرا جزيلا تبقى معنا يا نايف
لانه الحديث عن المونديال بقيه سن الرعود
اليك بعد قليل